is one person who knows all about being
Thrifty in the home kitchen it's my mum
God I love you I love you too
now you're gonna help me cook dinner and
give me some valuable tips on how to
save money in home kitchen right hello I
will do you will do Excellency easy
peasy
we're gonna make an amazing spicy
braised oxtail followed by a deliciously
juicy pudding chili poached pears with
star and East dust now oxtail is
something that we grew up with yeah
there's something you can do in the
morning and put it in the oven because
it has to be cooked really really slow
yes I'm gonna dust this in flour it's
amazing how many chefs are using oxtail
on their menus today it's incredible
it's fairly popular it's very cheap as
well it's amazing I used to make it
stretch for like five or six dinners I
don't exactly it's not that bad now I
know why we're also skinny growing up
it wasn't that bad I'm joking come on
you know I'm joking but you see
sometimes we went to The Butchers and
you had maybe extra two or three I used
to put in a saucepan and you had lovely
stock for soup what was that spicy soup
that really nice
and I used to make a good pot of scotch
broth Scotch broth I remember now we'll
peel a couple cloves of garlic no I'll
show you a quick way of getting that out
get your knife and just wash it a mess
peel them and I'll crush them in the
garnet Crusher okay
I'm gonna fry that off okay and get that
nice and brown and we've all braised it
in red wine and sort of chicken stock
before but I'm gonna get this done with
a Chinese influence the Chinese
absolutely love cooking oxtail
you started cooking at home quite early
on right 17 and a half 17 and a half
your mum died quite young very young 26
26 so who taught you how to cook
enough to tell you I think you just
learn as you get older and you learn by
your mistakes and then enjoy it yes I
did enjoy it yeah that was a nice
vegetable nut the fennel fennel isn't it
that lovely that's beautiful yeah a lot
of people do use it a lot of them use it
in salads but no one actually Cooks it
if you just slice that up man
now these are nice and brown
you look lovely yeah put the color on
there
you just sliced up the chili okay just
size it down and keep the seeds in there
because I want some heat as well
one thing he never used to do was work
with many spices there wasn't many
Chinese influences I wasn't very
adventurous with spicy Spike then no I
like ginger do you I love Ginger
especially fresh yeah coriander seeds a
little handful ten yeah
and soy sauce
and quite generous in soy sauce like
four or five tablespoons that helps give
it that saltiness and a nice dark Rich
color on the vegetables so as it braises
the meat tenderizes quicker I would
never do anything fennel and the
chillies and but it smells nothing does
that smell nice
and then a little bit of this this is a
rice wine vinegar yeah
what other tips would you give me in
order to save money on cooking what got
you through that tough time feeding all
six of us and holding two jobs
an hour and a half
then I would think right I'll make a
race putting up an apple pie and for the
same sort of heat use the other shelf in
the oven so you weren't just watching
the pennies in terms of the produce you
also cutting down the gas bill yeah wow
super Nan yeah Superman yeah some oxtail
back on top of the vegetables okay top
that up is that beef beef here is uh no
a really nice chicken stock why are you
putting chicken stock isn't it because
it's quite a sort of light fragrant way
of cooking oxtail because oxtail itself
is quite Rich yeah chicken Stock's nice
and light just cover it with stock
lovely color isn't it it's a beautiful
color a little taste there we go big
deep breath okay Nan
well that's lovely I can taste the
fennel on that is that nice that's
lovely
oh Jesus
damn water Finance
[Laughter]
take some water now it's not water is it
water come on while mum recovers from
the kick off the chili to go with my
Oriental influenced oxtail I'm Gonna
Knock up a quick fresh radish salad
take a bunch of radishes and separate
off the edible leaves
once washed thoroughly Place half the
radishes in the bowl with the leaves
chop the remaining radishes in half and
add them too
[Music]
next peel and finely slice a banana
shallot
add them to the radishes and Seasons
with salt and pepper
dress with a good squeeze of fresh lemon
juice and a drizzle of olive oil
then mix
radish salad it's that simple
Next Up dessert delicious poached pears
I Love Pears ready so we're gonna poach
them with a little bit of chili chili
a little bit of saffron no no
pan on take off a little slice down
there so they stand up nicely and then
peel
okay then and then the chili yeah hold
that up and just go down yep
through and open that up okay into the
water seeds in as well seeds in as well
oh hello holes what is that smell it
smells so good
a little bit of chili water and sugar
what are they holes
it's exactly that saffron is expensive
but you only need the tiniest little bit
a little pinch to make that water go
light and golden star needs so how comes
the chilies you've like sliced it at the
end and it's not put in half I want all
that flavor coming out of the chili
we're going to make
the most amazing star in East dust
Starry Stars dust wow did you get your
star nice in there seed up and then in
it's all his little seeds yeah and then
you start grinding
a little teaspoon of Ginger give it a
nice mix thank you mate and that's gonna
dust the top of the pears once they're
cooked right get your pears
drop them in there
[Music]
and that's what we're going to sprinkle
Ginger it's Darkness wow the rice is
that very good almost Lovely isn't it so
once they're cooked cooled down sprinkle
that over the top right have you guys
got homework yes
turn that down and let them fall
okay bye thank you guys
after an eight minute simmer our pair
should be ready no just get your knife
on put the knife through and see how
easy the knife is
so that means they're soft and cooked
now you can leave them in that overnight
two or three days all right and they
just get darker
and More Beautiful the good thing about
the cooking liquor is that you don't
throw that away because you can use that
again for reproaching
beautiful
and when they look impressive this
doesn't it
[Music]
because they're amazing
and just
doesn't
and then take your little
star in East dust
and just
dust
over look at this lovely now for my
favorite part
the oxtail wow
look at that
is beautiful
I'm just something else in your mouth
doesn't it
I love the way you see that just sliding
down the bone there's no waste in that
at all
you're carrying up to the table please
then oh yes I will do lovely and all
right I'll grab that that is beautiful
this is my ultimate Thrifty dinner
Sumptuous slow cooked Chinese braised
oxtail with a light and peppery radish
salad
followed by gorgeous chili poached pears
with star anise dust some of the best
hearty dinners I can think of are slow
cooked recipes made with robust deep
flavored ingredients and left to Bubble
away for hours until they become glossly
rich this is the sort of food that
really gives you plenty of energy and
protects you against cold winter weather
so for my ultimate Hearty dinner I'm
doing a dish to every home cook should
have a recipe for a great stick to your
ribs stew here's my favorite beef and
Ale with mustard dumplings
foreign
[Music]
first things first I'd like you to
season the students day
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah
good girl what's the flower going to do
dad the flower helps to Brown the beef
seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew I feel a bit
like marshmallows
look at the size of the chunks of the
beef
I'm going to cut my carrots literally
similar similar sizes right does that
mean they'll cook equally that's right
now these they're little pearl onions
I'm going to put them in whole as well
everything
has to stay the same otherwise it could
burn oh we've seen burn garlic before
Oh Matilda
should probably mention that
what is that
time time and what they
Bailey's Bailey's good girl tablespoon
of oil in the beef goes in first okay in
it's got a beautiful color
remember the carrots thyme in good girl
garlic pearl onions in
good
give that a really good mix up
our shoes
are very easy to make providing at the
beginning you give it a little bit of
love
now that's all juicy Brown
that's them that is beer and that's
going to deglaze the pan adding beer or
Stout helps to tenderize the beef and
give it a hearty delicious flavor
and that's the only way I want you to
taste beer
in a stew
yeah
I'm going to add in a couple of
teaspoons of tomato puree please
I'm saying three please
because it's so nice and there's one
final thing in there cover this tuna
steak with a big stock give that a
little mix with Daddy please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you start um serve it
oh yes is the Garlic going to be burnt
no excuse me
right and we always put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
be that's right not make the stew or
watery into the oven at 150 please tell
us for about two and a half hours and
now
getting focus on your homework
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato Classics in one twice baked
bubbling squid jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
we shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute and butter and add a dash of
water until tender
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and
cooked through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato Center
then Mash with a couple of knobs of
butter mix in the cabbage and season to
taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato Classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
right homework done yeah
mysterious chewing stewing let's get on
with our delicious hearty pear tart I've
been looking forward to this you and I
Chef I'm gonna prep the pears so if you
peel I'll top and tail into quarters
pears go soft in the oven very very
quickly so we're going to put them on a
tart we'll need to leave them whole half
or in quarter what's that in there
Ginger that's right that's stem Ginger
so when you use stem Ginger and fresh
ginger next add your stem Ginger a
little of the stem ginger syrup good
girl and some brown sugar to your
quartered pears
and then just grate some fresh ginger
off you go so it's a bit of a different
one to grate this because it doesn't
really come through like the cheese no
I'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there
right what we need to do now is give
that a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff we can make it so easy to do
so give me your finger
that's my center point I want you to get
the pairs going around
like that in a really nice Circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pears keep on sliding all over the place
yeah so egg wash the outside and I'm
going to show you a little trick so you
lift that up
like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
the pastry forms this nice little shelf
like a little money bag are you going to
do anything with the spare pairs oh yeah
I'm building that up then you see
the fresh ginger and those nice little
bits of stem Ginger let me go around
Blake
lurches on top
Tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully
it's a bit like snow isn't it now that
glazes the pastry so the pastry has this
really nice shine on there as well
finally the lemon on top
put that there
180 and in she goes
can you smell the beef
[Music]
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it
I want you to just I was hoping you'd
asked
taste
[Music]
how's that taste now
you're not allowed anymore
dumpling time flowering please I'm using
self-raising flour for a fluffy result
but if you like your dumplings hard use
plain flour next The Dumpling essential
suet that makes the dumplings nice and
moist
[Music]
by a generous dollop of grain mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round Another
Touch of warm water here your fingers
are now a nice little whisk fingers are
getting tired right now put your hand in
there now you should bring all that
dough together
actually the best way to get that nice
and clean sprinkles and flour on your
hands rub them together
all that will come off
it's a good way is it now you've got
this wonderful dumpling mixture how
squid is that oh
a little flower on your hands okay roll
these lengthways
and then I want you to follow my lap in
your hand
I'll figure
smell that mustard in there
huh
come on
other Chester or something like that
yes please
tell me
gently let's go in at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
and put that back into the oven
for 20 minutes to cook the dumplings now
if you open the door for daddy I'm going
to take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our petard has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby
would you like me to start testing yes
please
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job down very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look
delicious okay I'll check on the
dumplings
now look they've sort of doubled in size
whoa definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
I might have to have a quick taste
before we go just to check I mean we
have to be sure
[Music]
that is an amazing hearty beef stew
dumpling smoke the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate Hearty dinner a
comforting Rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and Ginger galette